tant qu'il y a de la vie il ya de
l'espoir les anciens salariés
d'arjowiggins en sont la preuve
il y à plus d'un an les dernières pas
patrie de la sarthe entamé une
liquidation judiciaire laissant quelques
600 salariés sans emploi
ce vendredi ils ont appelé le tribunal
de nanterre à revenir sur sa décision
histoire de prendre le temps de trouver
une offre de reprise sérieuse
nous on n'est pas du tout d'accord avec
ça d'autant plus que la date a été prise
pendant le confinement en secret le plus
grand secret personne ne savait on l'a
découvert par hasard
et donc c'est pas très cool on dit quand
même que c'est parfait respectueux des
citoyens et c'est pas parce qu'on est le
tribunal de nanterre qu'on a le droit de
faire des choses comme ça on va
interpeller les pouvoirs publics et la
première démarche à faire c'est
d'interpeller aussi le tribunal de
nanterre pour qu'il reporte cette
échéance du 29 mai qu qui si elle était
confirmée serait synonyme de fermeture
définitive du site
avec tout ce que ça peut représenter en
termes de malheurs et de détresse pour
notre territoire y compris sur les
questions sociales et environnementales
selon les citoyens sarthois et les
membres du collectif action citoyenne
pour l'intérêt général
il serait préférable pour la commune de
ne pas oublier le secteur de la
papeterie
en effet de nombreux professionnels du
secteur s'inquiètent d'une pénurie de
papier en france au profit du marché
asiatique
la visite d'un industriel britannique
spécialisée dans le démantèlement de
sites industriels ce 12 mai n'était donc
clairement pas la bienvenue
il ya une il ya une imposture là parce
que c'est pas un projet vous savez c'est
un monsieur k spéculateurs et à des
choux il vient ici il va démolir il va
rentabiliser les lieux et après il ya
les vendre en lots ça s'appelle pas un
projet industriel lui il était garé là
avec son 4 4 anglais et ils étaient tous
surpris de voir qu'ils avaient déjà
scandé team délégation on lui a dit que
nous on voulait garder les usines
et il était un peu occupé en bété deux
autres offres locales orientée vers la
production de papier recyclé et était
également à l'étude mais aucun
investisseur n'a souhaité financer ces
projets car l'industrie du papier est
considéré comme étant sur le déclin
si le tribunal de nanterre refuse le
délai supplémentaire demandé et si d'ici
au 29 mai prochain aucune offre n'est
accepté une vente aux enchères sera
organisée machine locaux seront mises à
prix le risque que le terrain devienne
une friche industrielle de plus dans une
région qui en compte déjà beaucoup
pour le sociologue